here's a question I've been sent which
is a pretty standard proof by
mathematical induction I've got this sum
over here 1 over K squared from 1 to N
and I want to show that it is lesser
than or equal to 2 minus 1 on M and
here's my domain it's just a fancy way
of writing where n is an integer it's a
positive a positive integer ok right
well how does every mathematical
induction proof start well I've got to
begin by testing the first allowable
value now since n is a positive integer
the very first one of that of those is N
equals 1 okay so it's a pretty simple
loading looking result to establish
what's the right-hand side equal to well
the right hand side is let's see 2 minus
1 over 1 that's just 1 okay what's the
left-hand side equal to the left-hand
side is the sum from k equals 1 that's
my starting point up to 1 so that's the
only term of 1 on K squared so that's
just 1 over 1 which is also equal to 1
now in this case I actually land on the
boundary but that's okay I've got an
equality there so therefore my left hand
side is indeed left less than or equal
to the right hand side so this is true
the inequality is satisfied for the
first allowable value so it's true
that's good we've be in trouble if that
wasn't true now what's the next step
well I have to assume this is the
inductive hypothesis is what it's called
I have to assume that this statement is
true for some value now by the way you
know the some value we usually pick is
usually K it's were a bad idea since
there are k's in the question so i'm
going to pick a number I'm gonna pick a
letter like N equals C for constant okay
we're C follows the same rules that n is
supposed to follow so it's a positive
integer okay so what does that look like
well just simply it's replacing all of
the ends in my original questions with C
so 1 on K squared here and it's less
than or equal to 2 minus 1 on C right so
there's my assumption
and now do I actually have to do where's
the work of the induction well here's
what I got proof that it's true for the
next value over okay now the next value
over is going to be C plus one okay so
what does the inequality look like when
I want to take this value well it's
going to be the sum from k equals 1 up
to c plus 1 on 1 on k squared less than
or equal to 2 minus and that C is now C
plus 1 okay now this is the hard part
this is where the work is so where do I
begin now probably the easiest way like
with most induction inequality proofs is
that I'm going to start with my
assumption and then I'm going to try and
twist and turn this so that I can arrive
here ok so the first thing I'm going to
say is by assumption this is my proof
now by assumption this is true like I'm
not I'm not proving it or anything I'm
just saying well it should be because
that's what my assumption is ok now
what's this sir what's his left-hand
side equal to well it's just it's just a
long some I don't know how many terms
there are what there are C times but I
don't know what size C is but I know how
this the pattern follows so it's going
to be one on one squared plus one on to
your squared one on three squared and
then all the way up until one on C
squared that's the very last term okay
and that apparently is equal to is
greater than or equal to less than or
equal to two minus one on C now remember
what I'm trying to do is twist and turn
this thing so that I can arrive at the
statement that I was trying to prove
which is this one here it's got C Plus
Ones and that kind of thing right now
how do I change this left-hand side so
that it's not the sum up from 1 to C but
the sum from 1 to C plus 1 all I have to
do is all these time to find and just
have to add the next one over right so
I'm going to have 1 on 1 squared 1 on 2
squared and so on I'm going to 1 and 1
on C squared and then the next term
along is 1 on C plus 1 squared okay now
if I add it to one side
I should add it to the other so that's
what I've got over here okay and now
this whole series on the left-hand side
I can rewrite it in Sigma notation okay
so that's now equal to the sum from 1 to
C plus 1 because that's what I did
adding this last value on on of 1 on K
squared so that's good my left-hand side
is looking exactly like I want it now
what do I have on the right side ok well
I've got this sort of awkward looking
jumble of terms what do i what am I
going to do with it
well because it's an inequality I don't
have to make it necessarily equal to
what I want but I've got to get it at
least close to or as good as this this
is what I'm after
ok now that looked kind of turned in
like how do you do that well I just have
to get it good enough I don't have to
they don't have to actually be equal to
each other ok so I mean the first step
that I would do is notice that the 2 and
the 2 they're they're fine ok so how can
I adjust this so it's going to look
resemble something like that ok well I
got two fractions I want to put them
into one so standard sort of procedure
is to get a common denominator right
so I've got my 2 minus at the front a
common denominator by the looks of
things would be C times C plus 1 squared
ok now if I make that my common
denominator what am I going to have on
the top I'll have a C plus 1 square
there and I'll have a seat over there ok
now what am I got over here well if I
expand this this is C squared plus 2 C
plus 1 plus C that's all over the same
denominator that hasn't changed okay now
before I start simplifying you know
where do I want to end up well I want to
end up at something that looks like this
okay now it's hard to see the connection
between the two because the denominators
are different what if the denominators
were the same well that twos out the
front that's the same this denoted a is
C times C plus 1 squared this is just C
plus 1 so what's the difference well
there's a factor of C and an extra
factor of C plus 1
right so that means that if I were to
change the denominator so that it would
equal right what will be on the top will
to make it equivalent it would be C
times C plus one okay now that's just C
squared plus C now hold on a second I
have a C square and a C on this new rule
in fact I have more than that
right so what I've got here is that this
is necessarily equal to two
- okay stay with me C squared plus C and
then I've got some some leftovers right
what have I got left over I've got a - C
plus one now that's all over C times C
plus one squared but I'm just going to
write that as two separate fractions
because it will be useful to me in a
second as I'm simplifying okay all right
now as we noticed the reason why I
picked out that C squared and that C is
because I can factorize them as C
outside of C plus one and that's C
outside of C plus one squared this guy
seems to be hanging over on the right
hand side rather awkwardly but I'll deal
with him in a second now what happens to
this well cancel cancel cancel one of
these will cancel so now what I've got
is two minus one on C plus one and then
I've got a I'm sorry this is actually
a.m. when I separated the fractions this
is actually a - don't forget that sign
carry over minus two C plus one on C
outside of C plus one squared okay
now pause for a second what was I trying
to show what I was trying to show that
it was less than or equal to two minus
one on C plus one right and I've shown
that it's less than or equal to two
minus one on C plus 1 minus something
else okay now you see what that means
let's just think about it like this if I
gave you some number right I wanted to
prove it to you that X was less than or
equal to five
okay well if I can prove to you that X
is less than or equal to five minus
three right then surely this imply
is that right because if it's less than
or equal to 2 then it must be a really
really small number
clearly it already satisfies this right
well that's exactly the same scenario
that I have here right let me try and
make it a little more obvious it all
depends on the fact that C is positive
okay so you get this piece of paper okay
let's just consider this Oh since C is
positive right therefore - outside of -
c plus 1 on C outside of C plus 1
squared that's what that's what I have
here on the UM on the end of my
inequality on the right hand side now
thing it surely is negative surely
because if C is positive that numerator
is going to be positive that denominator
is getting positive slapped a minus sign
on the front okay well if this is true
then I should be able to just add 2 on
sorry not - on 2 minus 1 on c plus 1
just add that to both sides of this
inequality so minus 2 C plus 1 C outside
of C plus 1/4 squared that's less than
this 2 minus 1 on C plus 1
I've just added this guy add it to both
sides so that's how I've changed from
that inequality to that inequality okay
but in my previous line of working what
I showed is that this whole left-hand
side right that guy has I've got sort of
two levels of inequalities right this
guy is a greater than or equal to the
Sigma notation that I had over here
from 1 to C plus 1 of 1 on K squared
okay
that's less than or equal to this minus
which in turn is less than or equal to
this okay so this is what I actually
want I actually want this guy on the
left and this guy on the right and I
actually am not that interested in this
guy in the middle right so since I know
that this is less than or equal to that
and that's less than equal to that I can
just sort of
get rid of this guy moving from the
middle right just like if I had you know
three is less than or equal to four
which is less than or equal to five I
can say well forget about four who's
interested I want I want the two guys on
the left on the right right well I'm
going to take those two and I'm
combining them into this one inequality
which is from K equals 1 C plus 1 of 1
on K squared that must be less than or
equal to 2 minus 1 on C plus 1 okay
and that's what I was trying to prove
that the statement is true the original
statement I started with it's true for C
plus 1 ok so I'm basically done now I've
shown that if I can know it's true for
one value C then I can know it's true
for the next value C plus 1 and I know
that the value is true for the first
allowable value namely if I come back
all the way to the beginning right here
that's true for N equals 1 so therefore
it must be true for 2 & 3 & 4 which is
all of the positive integers that I'm
after right so I can say therefore
statement is true for N equals 1 to 3
and so on
ie for all values Italia right for all
values of n that are positive integers
and that's the proof